[Music]
you
YouTube just loves my friends this is
guns on here welcome to my thirty second
episode of chess traps series in this
episode I'm going to show you one of the
high profile trap in the Queens gambit
declined a modern variation from the
black perspective the qgd arises after
the falling model
d4 d5 c4 e6 Knight to c3 Knight to f6
and now by far most popular choice is
Bishop to g5 pinning down the night thus
pressurizing the D Phi square we're here
the old movies Bishop to e7 however in
this episode we are going to look at the
modern variation which start with D
capture c4 give up the center and
grabbing the power
now as I have highlighted over here
white has few choices and amongst them
efore is by far the most popular choice
however if you open and continue it
either the move Knight to f3 or e3 then
this line will transpose into the Queens
gambit accepted and a sample variation
goes like this III a6 Bishop captures a
fool now black take the claim on the
Queen side with c5 and after Knight to
f3 B Phi Bishop goes anywhere we will
continue with Bishop to b7 castle and
937 and as you can see black simple plan
of campaign is he wants to play Bishop
to e7 castle and then quickly undermine
the white center which give him the fair
share of the play in the upcoming medal
game
so if you want to include this lie in
your repute ah then you definitely look
out this variation in depth
ok-hee for what else so white is more
than happy as not only he get this
wonderful center but he's going to get
his spawn back and what more you can ask
from the opening
well that's fine but black has a nice
cunning move in the picture namely
Bishop to e7 unpinning the night and
asking white are you ready to go into my
trapping business well again the most
popular choice in this position is
Bishop capture c4 and that's where our
trap springs into the picture however
just for your understanding if you open
in here continue with Knight to f3 then
I think the simplest continuation start
with at 6 and white again has to be
careful as Bishop to h4 and leads
through the same trap as we are about to
see so more or less white obliged to
capture this night and after Bishop
captures f6 Bishop captures f6 and the
move Bishop capture Sifu yes indeed
White has a wonderful center and a
better peace development but on the
counterpart black has a bishop pair and
everybody knows that in open game this
factor is a huge bonus for the black
camp
so finally let's see what's going on
after the move Bishop to c4 which is in
fact if you check in online database
there are roughly 150 games goes into
this direction where unfortunately for
the wide he fall into the trap on the
sixth move of the game
the trappy business start with this
deciding blow yup it's night captures
efore BAM
so suddenly black Vince the pong and all
the technical aspects are favoring the
black cap
now as the white Bishop has been
attacked White has the only move namely
Bishop captures a seven
however if white continue with Knight
captures a fool then the simplest
variation is Bishop captures defy Knight
captures g5 and Queen captures g5 which
not only simplified the position with a
clear point advantage but black has some
ongoing pressure on the g2 pawn which
give him sufficient age to win this game
okay Bishop captures Issa one is forced
and black response is also forced he has
to take knight on c3 counter-attacking
the white queen
again there are three replies has been
tried and amongst them I think Queen to
g4 is the most critical however first of
all let's see what's going on in other
replies the first dubious response white
can play over here is B capture c3 and
after that black is completely fine as
after Queen captures a seven with the
naked eye
one can see there black emerged with an
extra pawn and white doesn't have a
single compensation for it so that
variation straight away goes into the
dustbin let's check out the second
option namely Bishop captures d8 and I
think this is where the calculation
comes into the picture again black
responses force black has to capture on
Devon
and when white get his pawn back with
Bishop capture c7 which at first sight
looks so gold black has equally strong
reply namely night captors b2 attacking
the bishop and gaining one more time
one-point advantage the point is once
the bishop move let's say Bishop to e2
Black Knight has this easy escape route
with Knight to e4 and once that happened
with extra pawn advantage black
instantly getting the upper hand in the
game
you
last but not least what happens if you
opponent continue with the most critical
move Queen to g4 and to my surprise
there are only three games played with
this variation and I'm afraid black
doesn't replied properly the correct
move in this position is King captures
c7 which at first sight looks completely
strange right but it has his own point
as black wants to give his extra pawn on
the board now apart from King captures
a7 one can also try the move Queen
captures c7
and the point is after the MOOC Queen
captures g7 which is the obvious
response Black has this nice tactical
resource Quinn to befall which gives him
great attacking chances on the right Lu
scheme sitting in the center the reason
why this is not my first choice as after
the following continuation Queen
captures rook King to e7 White has three
major choices and specially after the
move b3 the position is very unclear for
the black camp
but if you are more than confident to
play this line over the board then you
should definitely try it as a spur the
engine this gives a clear advantage to
the black amp
however I think my first preference is
to go with King captious a seven as it
is very straightforward and it is not
easy for white to justify his pawn loss
for example if we continue with Queen
cactus g7 then we can simply continue
with Knight to e4 and black emerge with
extra piece so that's not a great choice
for the white the second option if white
gives the check to the black King which
is not a good option either the simple
reason is let's say after Queen to h4
check black and calmly play King to d7
and now in the view of White Queen is
hanging as well as the knight can escape
white responses force he has to exchange
the Queen and then take the knight on c3
where again black emerged with a clear
pawn advantage so more or less at this
point white is forced to capture the
knight on c3
which take the piece back instantly but
now comes the point behind the move King
cactus c7 as black is going to continue
with King to f8 protecting the g7 pawn
and the obvious plan in the situation is
g6
King to g7 and because white doesn't
have dark square bishop his King is
quite safe at the g7 sponge
the big surprising point about this
variation is there is not a single game
reached to this position so with some
careful study you can definitely go for
the full point
I just like to give you a sample line
where even though with the bass play by
white/black still obtain a very good
position and a clear pond advantage
night to have three completing the piece
development and you already know blacks
next move right yup
it's g6 and if white continued with
solid moves then black and do artificial
castle and seriously claim a winning
advantage so it has to go for this
aggressive move
h4 trying to open up the black King now
the key thing you have to remember in
this line is whenever that four happens
you should not allow white to play the
match five and accordingly we are going
to play the match file counter attacking
the White Queen
after Queen to e4 King to g7 once we can
take out this rook and put the Queen on
lovely squares it is very hard for white
to justify his loss of pole well okay
White has this lovely square for his
knight namely Knight to g5 but apart
from looking pretty there that night is
absolutely doing no harm to the black
camp we can calmly continue with rook to
a fade and after castle on the Kings
side the important plan you have to
remember is this Knight maneuver Knight
to d7 heading towards important Square
abscess and after the base continuation
that is rook f2 even Knight to f6 Queen
to f4 and now Queen to d6 trying to
exchange Queen when we upon up and once
we develop of light square Bishop I
think it is only black who is playing
for the win in such a situation with a
clear decisive pond
advantage
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful trap in the qgd
modern variation remember once you open
and played the move Bishop capture
seafood give him this ultimate shock had
the sixth Moo of the game and no matter
however white continue with some good
preparation you can not chop some good
points and the tounament actists well
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
you